[Music]
welcome to the drama behind the scene
show I'm your house definition and in a
recent interview Kevin Hart got pretty
vocal about his feelings towards the
Game of Thrones finale when promoting
the secret life of pets - in the
following interview which was posted by
extra TV the comedian discusses all of
his thoughts on the way that Game of
Thrones has been handled by HBO as well
as some of the quote-unquote choices
that were made in the season 8 finale
I think Kevin Hart absolutely nails it
here so without further ado let's get
into the clip now you okay are you
because a lot of people thrown off this
squeeze with the whole Game of Thrones
yeah look this is a prime example of let
people do the work okay
that man was writing them books and
they're granted he may have taken a long
time these books are amazing no okay you
gotta leave that man alone
let him finish the books instead they
took it and they went and created stuff
and altered and changed and it just
didn't end the way it was supposed to
they didn't let that that man finished
the books so my suggestion is to send
him to a to an island somewhere
let him finish the books and give us the
real ending that we deserve it's too
much time and energy put into such an
amazing show well Kevin signed a
petition
I will not only sign a petition I will
put my face on the front of the day I
won't pamphlet that y'all taken around
with so many questions man stare see
ain't supposed to die like that
that's supposed to be a bloody death why
didn't a dragon why didn't a dragon try
to burn Jon Snow and then does snow
survive the burning because he's a
Targaryen what I mean there's so many
questions
oh goodness how great a can of worms I'm
sorry Kevin a glitch
if he's a prisoner he can't dictate how
the king should be determined to be so
much man let it out okay so what I love
about this is that it sort of discusses
the rights of a creator versus the
people who own the creative property
george RR martin has been pretty vocal
about his dislike of the way that the
characters have been handled in their
live-action adaptation and I think Hart
is right in what he's saying which is
that HBO and the D&D kind of rushed the
final season without really
understanding why certain characters had
made certain moves in the past which led
to a very confusing finale it kind of
brings up the debate over who actually
owns these characters and if you create
something then sell it does that give
other people the right to take your
property and discover their own stories
or should the creator be given the time
that they need to finish the work before
it's adapted I really don't know it's an
interesting discussion so definitely
leave your thoughts on that in the
comments below I do love how hard is
hilarious through the interview and yeah
if the petition had his face on it then
I think it would have probably got
everyone signing it now why I hate this
interview is because it reminds me of
all the things that I hated about the
finale I don't think I'll ever be okay
with the way that Cersei died just
because I just feel it was a bit too
much of an easy way out for the
character that also robbed area of
getting her revenge on the person who's
basically ruined her life either her or
Jaime Kilner would have been nice look I
don't want to get into this rabbit hole
of things that would do a fix the season
a finale because it would be a five hour
long video anyway I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this interview and if you
agree with hard or disagree with him
should we just like Game of Thrones go
and completely forget about what what do
you mean they're making a prequel oh not
this again anyway comment below and let
me know and if you enjoyed this video
then please like it and make sure you
check out my coverage on what Seth Rogen
had to say about the finale of the
season which would be linked after this
Seth is pretty vocal on his feelings too
so yeah it's a great watch if you want
to come talk to me about movies TV show
those games and comic books then you can
follow me on Twitter a definition why
team it's the best way to get in touch
with me and it's the perfect place to
suggest new videos and content also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of John with curry on
blu-ray and all you have to do to be in
with a chance of winning is to like this
video make sure that you subscribe to
the channel and leave your thoughts on
what Kevin Hart said in the comment
section below the warden will be chosen
at random on September the 10th and the
blu-ray will be shipped out from then to
ever get surprised so best of luck to
everyone who takes part this is the
channel for people who are never missing
television so if that's the kind of
thing you like you need to subscribe to
definition thanks again for taking the
time to watch this you've been the best
and I'll see you next time take care
peace
you
[Music]